foreign
everybody if your dial-up is working we
are live streaming on the internet I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report and
we've got another Friday Round Table
Extravaganza for you joining me today is
the sub stacked journalist and author of
the gray lady winked how the New York
Times misreporting distortions and
fabrications radically alter history
Ashley rinsberg and the host of the Liz
wheeler show Liz wheeler Ashley Liz
welcome back to the Reuben report
thank you Dave
hi Dave thanks for having me Ashley you
mentioned right before we started that
last time I had you on was also the day
after a trump indictment that was the uh
the New York indictment obviously he was
indicted uh by a federal uh court
yesterday and apparently will be in
Miami at a federal courthouse on Tuesday
we'll get to that uh well you know what
let's just get to it right now here we
go Donald Trump has been indicted again
I roll right there uh we've got some
info from the daily wire uh former
president Donald Trump said Thursday
evening that he has been indicted in the
federal criminal investigation into his
handling of classified material the
former president who turned 77 next week
added that he has been summoned to
appear at the federal courthouse in
Miami on Tuesday at 3 P.M ABC news
Catherine falder said during a special
report on the network that Trump appears
to have been hit with seven charges
ranging from willful retention of
national defense information conspiracy
a scheme to conceal and false statements
and repercussions okay so let's just
start with these accusations that seem
to only go in One Direction because as
you guys know Joe Biden also has been
exposed to having classified documents
his classified documents by the way were
from when he was vice president which
you do not have the authority to
declassify documents and actually real
quick why don't we throw this tweet up
this is just from a random account on
Twitter Chicago Ray and you may remember
this image captured image below of the
only person who wasn't authorized by our
constitution to have classified
documents in his possession if the
justice department looks closely he's
driving his Corvette his name is Joe
Biden classified doc circled in red now
lock him up okay Liz let's start with
you on this one uh we all see the
asymmetry of this thing
but at some point uh Trump is just
getting hit relentlessly and it might
take some kind of toll right
I mean listen I have to disagree with
you a little bit on the validity of
these charges when you build yourself a
private email server and you put that
email server in a bathroom closet in
your apartment in New York and then when
you receive a subpoena for the
classified information that you store on
this unsecured Homebrew email server and
instead of turning over that information
you use bleach bid in a hammer to
actually destroy it in the face of this
legal subpoena I think charges are
entirely appropriate Donald Trump Donald
Trump deserves what he's getting oh wait
wait a second here did I say Donald
Trump I meant Hillary Clinton this is
this is so very clever we can laugh
because it yes thank you yes thank you
um we can laugh because it's funny but
it's also not funny this is a two-tiered
system of justice that that we're
experiencing in our nation it doesn't
matter if you like trump it doesn't
matter if you want to vote for trump it
doesn't matter what you think of Donald
Trump if you sit back and allow this to
happen Dave it's going to happen to any
one of us the federal government has
weapon is the power of law enforcement
and of our criminal justice system and
they are they're aiming this
weaponization against people whose
political beliefs they disagree with
that's all that's all I mean we had not
just Biden not just Hillary we had Pence
who also had classified documents at at
their at their private residences and of
course Donald Trump is the only one who
had authority to declassify whatever he
wanted it's it's a very sad day for our
country I don't even care how it impacts
the campaigns at this point this is much
larger than the very beginning of
presidential campaigns yeah I actually
just want to reiterate something that
Liz is saying here you know I've I've
obviously been very frustrated with
Trump over the last two or three months
some of the what I think are sort of
over-the-top attacks on Florida and
DeSantis and everything else I have no
problem agreeing with literally
everything you said right there and
publicly stating it and everything else
because there's a difference between
campaigning and rhetoric and all that
stuff and and Law and Order uh Ashley
it's it's the it's the inconsistent
consistency between how we treat these
things that I think is really upsetting
people right now to everything that Liz
just said like people see the documents
in the Biden garage again not he didn't
even have the authority to do it because
he was VP not president it's not a
secure location as Liz said Pence also
had them Pence was VP
etc
yeah and you know we the fact that we've
been talking about this as an issue is
um solely because it's been used to go
after Trump I mean we've never heard of
such a thing before and it's it Beggars
belief to think that nobody in the
history of American government had taken
home classified documents and not given
them back I mean there are probably
Legions of people from all ranks of
government who have done that and I
can't recall in my lifetime seeing a
sort of all of government response to
this so-called National crisis it only
started when they discovered a weak
point with Trump and that he had some of
these documents and then it went on to
Biden I think you know just so they
probably front ran it just so it didn't
come out
um but I really do think the tweet that
won this whole thing was David sacks
saying that everyone knows that if
you're going to keep classified
documents at home it should be kept in
your Corvette and that's pretty much it
I mean like there's not much more to say
what I really do think though is that
beyond all the BS people just know this
I mean you can you can see it it's kind
of a side-by-side thing Trump had
documents Biden had documents Trump has
charges Biden doesn't have charges it
speaks for itself
Liz do you have any reason to believe
that the government will turn back on
this like whether we look at the New
York case which was extremely flimsy
whether we'll find out a little bit more
on this one but is there any reason to
think that even if we all basically all
sort of sane people whether they love
Trump or a trump kind of agree a
weaponization of government is not good
that they'll ever turn back or ever stop
this there's also a case coming in
Georgia so we know more on the docket
well I like to make sure that everyone
goes into their weekend feeling really
happy and upbeat and hopeful So my
answer to this is no there's no reason
to think that these people are going to
turn back because they're I mean this
was their intention this was their
intention all along it gives me no
pleasure to say that I accurately
predicted that this would happen in this
exact way over six months ago nine
months ago when I said listen this this
raid on Mar-A-Lago the FBI staging this
rate in the way that they did when
Trump's teams were cooperating when he
had his lawyers there Trump even
interacted with FBI agents who or
national archives
um Representatives who were at his at
his residence before the raid happened
he was he was cooperating he put a lock
on a different room to store these
documents because they were worried
about the security of these documents
like there was no reason to think that
at a place a presidential residence that
was secured by secret service and this
was not even digital information these
were hard copies someone would have to
go in and steal them or take a photo of
them there was no reason to think this
was a threat to National Security in any
way shape or form they did this they
staged this raid in order to elevate
this situation or this invented
situation in the eyes of the American
people so that the American people would
be conditioned to accept these charges
these charges their intention for these
charges was always to charge Trump
probably under the Espionage Act to
charge him in a way that would not only
cause him to serve time in prison but to
prevent him from being allowed to run
for president I mean anybody who gives
the benefit of the doubt to the security
State anybody who gives the benefit of
the doubt to our federal law enforcement
apparatus hasn't been paying attention
to the fact that since president Trump
announced that he was running for
president in 2015 the federal government
has weaponized themselves used
themselves as a weapon to try to
overturn our voices subvert our will and
unseat him as duly elected president
Ashley isn't there also like just a boy
who cried wolf element to this like
we've been through two impeachments
we've been through Russia hoax and
Ukraine hoax and this and that and he
walked down the stairs slowly once so we
better 25th amendment him like they've
so thrown out the kitchen sink that even
if there was something legit here even
if there is I have no reason to believe
there is but even if there was that
people would just be like no no no no
this is too freaking obvious we've we've
been through this game before and you're
just not doing it to Biden in the Dems
yeah or any other president in American
history I mean there's kind of this
unspoken rule that you don't go after
presidents because what ends up
happening is this endless Tit for Tat
where you just go this political
weaponization of the Justice apparatus
and that's what we're seeing start right
now the so the last time I came on your
show and as you said we we had the first
indictment with Alvin Bragg I wrote a
Newsweek op-ed saying this is a blunder
of historic proportion it's not because
I think that the charges are necessarily
wrong I don't actually know but once you
start weaponizing the justice system in
a in such a political manner we're
talking about the president former
president United States candidate to be
president again you are opening a can of
worms you're not going to ever close
again this is going to end badly and in
part because it's going to erode what
little trust people have left in that
system and in the system in general so I
think this is boycard Wolf absolutely
but I think it's actually much much
worse than that as well right well it's
also been at a republic level stuff
because at some point if you keep if
everybody that's in power thinks that
they're gonna One Day end up in jail
well then they're just not going to give
up power I mean that's literally how
banana republics are formed I want to
read the the tweet that Ron DeSantis put
up because I saw a bunch of people were
like oh it's happening in Miami it must
have something to do with DeSantis it
has nothing to do with the state of
Florida it's a federal courthouse that
is not associated with Florida there are
federal courthouses obviously in every
state but I thought the statement was
quite good the weaponization of the
federal law enforcement of federal law
enforcement represents a mortal threat
to a free Society we have for years
witnessed an uneven application of the
law depending on political affiliation
why so zealous in pursuing Trump yet so
passive about Hillary or Hunter the
DeSantis Administration will bring
accountability to the Department of
Justice excise political bias and end
weaponization once and for all I mean
Liz I guess that that would be the Hope
whether he can do it who knows he has a
pretty good track record on doing the
things he set out to do but it's it's
the Hope right
yeah that's an incredibly powerful
statement he phrased it exactly the way
that he should he condemned exactly what
the Department of Justice is doing
specifically to Trump without being
vague and he also acknowledged that this
is a wider problem that it's not just an
isolated incident with President Trump
listen the reason that the swamp was not
fully drained under the Trump
Administration wasn't because Trump
somehow failed to follow through on this
promise because he didn't want to it's
because the American people and this
included Trump I believe didn't realize
the extent of the swamp so when we're
talking about the swamp we're of course
talking about the administrative state
so any Republican who wants to fight
against the weaponization of the
Department of Justice or the
weaponization of our of our federal
bureaucracy is actually talking about
fighting against the administrative
State they have to abolish the
administrative state if we are going to
eliminate this otherwise you can play
whack-a-mole with particularly corrupt
individuals like Anthony fauci or
Merrick Garland or whoever you want to
name as specifically but until we get
rid of this expansive administrative
state where these bureaucrats have so
much power you you can tweet all you
want you can tweet until the cows come
home but it's not going to change it's
actually one of the litmus tests that
I'm using to determine who I'm going to
vote for in the Republican primary is
which candidate understands the reality
of the threat of the administrative
State and can articulate a plan a
workable practical plan that they can
execute on that would that would abolish
it I think that's a great point and
wouldn't it be so refreshing if that's
what say Trump and DeSantis were
debating constantly like which one of us
can do this better wouldn't that be
great we would all be like oh what what
a joy to have a substantive debate on
that but let's shift for a second to
another guy who I'm fairly certain wants
to be president and might just be
waiting for Joe Biden to fall uh one
more time Gavin Newsom lizard person
Gavin Newsom out of California he is
very upset that Ron DeSantis sent 36
illegal immigrants not migrants or any
other soft word illegal immigrants who
broke the law by coming here in the
first place Place Ron DeSantis sent him
on a plane to California and Gavin
Newsom despite the fact that he's got a
sanctuary State and his Sanctuary cities
and nobody's illegal and we love
diversity and it's our strength he's not
happy about it I'm very confused
these flights of Asylum Seekers that are
being brought to Sacramento there have
been two of them now they've been
described as state-sanctioned kidnapping
by the Attorney General of of this state
of California you tweeted directly at
the governor of Florida Ron DeSantis I
want to get this right you called him a
small pathetic man and asked quote
kidnapping charges is that is that what
you believe happened the Florida
kidnapped migrants and brought them to
California I think I've been generous
small and pathetic
uh very generous he's just weakness
masquerading his strength
yeah he's flailing
desperate for attention let's just level
sit here let's level set here's a
governor from the state of Florida
that is using taxpayer money and he had
to go to another state
to find people under false pretense I
don't think this I know this I talked to
the migrants lied to them took them into
another state by bus and then took them
on a chartered flight to Sacramento
lying to them that they had help on the
other side knocked on the door and they
left these migrants right there on the
steps what kind of human being does that
guys let's level set right here I I
really think Gavin Newsom is the devil
like if the devil exists in in human
form his disconnect from the truth
actually makes him devil like uh before
I let you guys try man I thought I've
had a particularly good tweet on this if
I dare quote myself on my own show let's
put this up uh lizard person Gavin
Newsom is very upset that Ron DeSantis
sent 36 illegal immigrants to California
Phoenix I needed to roll for me on the
rest of that so I can see it
uh
uh here we go why doesn't he just uh
house them on his little faster for me
Phoenix Vineyard maybe he could even
find work for them I'm sure they'd enjoy
a nice glass of Pinot Noir after their
long Voyage here's a link for the other
illegals who want to swing by looks
pretty Swank so that's his Winery plump
Jack Winery and looks like he's got
plenty of room there and he said he's a
sanctuary state in a sanctuary City so I
don't know what he's so upset by also I
haven't heard one single person in
Florida complaining that any dollars
were used to get illegals out of here we
are a law an order State uh Ashley I
don't like Gavin Newsom take it from
there
um yeah I don't like it much either when
I he was married when I lived in San
Francisco and you just got a kind of a
greasy feel off of him and absolutely
you know you you would think that if he
were really behind his message about
being a sanctuary State and believing in
that in principle he would spend the
time on air welcoming those people to
his State and uh accepting all the
benefit that they bring but you know I
think there's there's also the this
other case of you know what's going on
in California and I think this is kind
of a great way to distract from that
where we have
tens of thousands if not many more
people dying of Fentanyl and
homelessness and related
um diseases and Addictions on the
streets of California on the Streets of
San Francisco and Los Angeles and that
is a crisis I mean 36 people you know
maybe it's unseemly to fly them across
country or whatever I don't know and I
don't really care but I do think when
you've got tens of thousands of young
people and and people of All Sorts dying
on the streets of the wealthiest state
in the nation and and
you know by the sixth largest economy in
the world as as it's usually uh
portrayed I think you've got a real big
question as to why he's not talking
about that issue Liz I want to play some
we're going to play some b-roll so you
can talk over this video right now so
there's some pictures and video here
these are the 36 people look at the
shades on that guy those are pretty cool
but look at these guys they all look
like they're in their 20s and 30s
they're on a cool private jet I've only
been on one of those once look she's
having a ball look at these guys they're
in a party van having a blast look at
that they're in all their clothes look
clean and everything else there's
there's interviews with them where they
say they're thrilled to be going to Cali
Liz the poor and the tired of the
huddled masses they wish they could be
these guys huh
listen it was brilliant by uh the people
that worked for governor DeSantis to
take these videos and to have these
migrants sign consent forms informed
consent informed consent because it
really debunks
um these arguments that Gavin Newsom is
throwing at us and listen I would just
invite everyone watching and listening
to the show to view
um to view Governor Newsom I should say
the way that I do and that is to view
him as cosplaying Andy Garcia he's he's
cosplaying a villain here and if you
look at him if you look at him through
that lens he's a lot more tolerable but
listen the rage that you hear in
Newsome's voice is not rage over 36
illegal aliens coming into California
it's not even rage at being outsmarted
by
um DeSantis which I'm sure does
infuriate him his actual rage has to do
with the fact that he has been setting
himself up to be to run for president as
a Democrat for the past his well his
entire tenure as governor of California
he expected to be given that opportunity
to be given that chance he thought he
was The Heir Apparent to the 2024
Democrat presidential nomination and
then Biden this walking vegetable
decides to or his people tell him that
he will be running for president again
and Gavin Newsom is panicking because
everything he's done as Governor has a
disastrous consequence he has run
California into the ground all three of
us Ashley Dave and I have all lived in
California we all moved away from
California because it is such a disaster
Zone even though we love it and the top
the clock is ticking he knows that he
can't hide the disastrous consequences
of what he's done in California from the
country that much longer he has a very
short very narrow window of opportunity
to be able to say hey I did all the
radical leftist things that the radical
leftists wanted me to do therefore I
deserve to be president and now he only
has like five minutes before it runs
into the ground and people are like dude
that doesn't work we don't want you to
run for president so that's the actual
source of his rage no illegal aliens we
should give credit where credit's due
Liz Liz and I only fled the state Ashley
you actually fled the country I I kind
of admire that
um let's let's listen to DeSantis so he
uh he explained exactly why he did this
so here's the thing
these Sanctuary jurisdictions are part
of the reason we have this problem
because they have endorsed and agitated
for these types of open border policies
they have bragged that they are
Sanctuary jurisdictions they attack
previous administration's efforts to try
to have border security and so that's
the policies they've taken out and then
what when when they have to deal with
some of the fruits of that they all of a
sudden become very very upset about that
uh well what are these people having to
deal with um here I don't see the
sympathy for them and so um you know the
reality is is I think the Border should
be closed I don't think we should have
any of this but if there's a policy to
have an open border then I think the
sanctuary jurisdiction should be the
ones that have to bear that we're not a
sanctuary in Florida and yes we know
people want to come and so the more we
can divert before we even have to get
there is good for our our state why
don't we all just come together
and say the current policy is a failure
any country worth its salt would have
control over its own borders we have too
many Americans dying and this is totally
unacceptable and let's get the federal
government to do to reverse course
you know just on the the tone and the
body language when you're telling the
truth versus lying it's just so obvious
who's in the right here but to his last
Point shouldn't Gavin Newsom even if
Gavin Newsom believes that tally should
be a sanctuary state in San Francisco we
should just welcome more illegals to
enjoy the the free Fentanyl and
everything shouldn't his frustration be
with Biden first if you're really upset
by illegal immigrants shouldn't it be
that he's upset with Biden and not Ron
DeSantis Ashley
yeah well you know I think he's probably
upset with Biden for the reasons that
Liz laid out and uh he's channeling that
race and I love the Andy Garcia cosplay
that's that's amazing but um yeah I
think we we all are failing the the
country's failing in its duty to secure
its border
um we can all agree that immigration is
an amazing thing for America and and
appreciate it and and also be grateful
for immigrants I'm an immigrant or I was
an immigrant to America
um but that doesn't mean that we should
have lawlessness on the southern border
or any part of the Border we do need a
secure border as any country does and
Biden is not just failing in that he is
willfully neglecting it he has decided
to completely just wash over that entire
issue and what that's doing is creating
chaos creating crisis and uh creating an
opportunity for people like Newsome to
get a message out like that one so I
think in that regard he's probably
grateful to Biden because it gives him a
little bit of a platform a bit of a
plank to run on and a bit of a moment to
become uh righteous and sanctimonious
about it but um I think you know the
buck ought to stop at Biden but nobody's
holding him accountable and that of
course has to do with media I mean the
media is just not talking about the
issue not talking about the seriousness
and not talking about Biden's duty to do
something whatever policy you want if
you want a left-wing policy or
right-wing policy it's got to be
something but right now it's nothing
right because then the the sanctimony
about it seems ridiculous you don't care
when El Paso Airport is filled or the
Border towns are filled with all of
these illegals but then suddenly when 20
of them show up in Martha's Vineyard you
people all freak out Liz did you see the
video this week we played it earlier in
the week I'm guessing you saw it of RFK
Jr at the Border in Arizona at 2 30 in
the morning and hundreds of migrants are
passing through behind him and here's a
Democrat calling for a closed border
that that is so out of touch I think
with
well certainly what the Democrat Party
or the machine wants I don't know about
the average Democrat but it's like isn't
that the guy you should be paying
attention to instead of Gavin Newsom if
you're if you're a sane Democrat for
whoever's left
oh definitely I mean RFK Jr Dave if if
he were an example of what the
Democratic party was I'm not I'm not
sure that we would he might put us out
of work let's just say we wouldn't have
these these intense culture wars to be
fighting if he were if he were
representative of the democratic party
but listen what what Ashley said is
correct about the media and the elite in
Washington DC dismissing what's
happening at the border it's not just
that they're out of touch out of touch
kind of the insinuation with the phrase
out of touch is that they just you know
they haven't experienced it themselves
they don't really have a tangible
feeling associated with it I would I
would Elevate that and say it's actually
a malicious snobbery when when I say
malicious snobbery it's snobbery because
they actually aren't going to suffer the
repercussions of an open border because
they have they even live in a gated
community or they're Untouched by
Untouched by you know these Sanctuary
jurisdictions but it's malicious because
they're not stupid they know that other
people will be harmed other people will
be hurt by having an open border I mean
the fact that this video that you're
referencing RFK Jr at the border with
hundreds of thousands of people coming
across this is I mean it's not like this
is an isolated incident it's not like
this video is a one of a kind this is
something that we're seeing every day
all the con all the time and it is a
deliberate decision by the Biden
Administration we know this because we
can just contrast it to two three years
ago what Trump was doing stopped this
flow of illegal aliens across our border
with several specific policies like
remain in Mexico and ending Catch and
Release and you know title 42 these
things stopped the flow Biden
deliberately reversed them and the
American people I mean the reason the
media is quiet about this is because it
doesn't matter whether you're a Democrat
or Republican the American people
understand that this is a threat to our
country and a threat to our safety
Ashley one more thing on Gavin
specifically
um look everyone knows he was mayor of
San Francisco he destroyed that City it
was one it was literally one of the most
beautiful cities in America the first
time I went to San Francisco about 15
years ago it's the first city that I
ever just showed up and within an hour I
was like I could live here it was so
wonderful and now it is a dystopian
nightmare that kind of it should be I
always say this but it every 6 30
newscast ABC NBC CBS should be leading
with what's going on in San Francisco it
is absolutely unbelievable he destroyed
that he in essence now has destroyed
California and he dares to want to be
president I mean I guess that proves
both of your point about what the media
does to these people you can always fail
up
yeah I think it's um you know he he's a
good silhouette and I think that's what
we what the media is seeking today so
when it looks looks the part speaks the
part has the right connections and uh
delivers the right messaging for the
media for the media's point of view but
uh the track record is abysmal and of
course what happened in California
during covid was even more so I mean it
was a complete disaster forcing Toddlers
and young children to wear cotton masks
that did nothing just for performative
reasons
um I think it's actually a bit sick so
you know as Liz mentioned I I came from
California I grew up in California I
lived in California I lived in San
Francisco uh right after the the.com
bubble burst and I loved it it was the
most magical place to be and at this
point I wouldn't just not go back to San
Francisco I really wouldn't go back to
California for so many reasons and yeah
Newsome and uh the these system of idea
ideology and ideas that he is
representative of caused that I mean it
is a direct it's not correlation it is
causation and we just need to be aware
of that let's jump over to two other
guys that announced they're running for
president this week Gavin obviously is
waiting for his moment if Joe falls
again uh Chris Christie first announced
at a town hall at the end of it
you will have no doubt in your mind
who I am
and what I stand for and whether I
deserve it
so that's why I came back to Saint
anselms and that's why I came back to
Manchester and that's why I came back to
New Hampshire to tell all of you that I
intend to seek the Republican nomination
for president United States in 2024 and
I want your support
Liz who who do you think he thinks is
his base or who do you think he thinks
is actually supporting him I don't think
he's a terrible guy he was actually a
pretty good governor of Jersey and
unfortunately Jersey's pretty solidly
blue now uh more than I think it should
be
um but like who does who's he really
talking to like what's the angle here
oh you're nicer than me Dave I actively
dislike Chris Christie he basically he
hugged Obama into the White House in
2012. I mean I I think that he he Bears
a lot of responsibility for that so the
way that I've been analyzing some of
these Republican candidates when they
jump in the race because we all either
like laugh we were just ash and I were
just sitting here laughing as we see him
announcing this we're laughing or people
are scratching their head like wondering
are are you crazy there's a couple of
questions that I've been asking myself
as like a framework to analyze these
people and the first question is can
they win the obvious answer here with
Chris Christie's no we can't win he has
no constituency so the second question
that I ask is okay well does he have a
book that he's trying to promote does he
have a business he's trying to
um that he's trying to build the answer
to that with Chris Christie is no so the
third question is well is he trying to
suck up to the front runner of the front
runner or the expected Republican
nominee to maybe get a cushy
Administration role he did that the last
time with Trump but given the fact that
this is kind of an anti-trump campaign I
think the answer is no so the fourth
question really speaks to Chris Christie
here and that is is he just delusional
all and I'm sorry to say I think the
answer is yes he's just delusional he
actually thinks he can be president and
he's never going to be you know the
thing is sometimes people dress like a
certain degree of the Limelight and if
you're a non-effective republican the
media loves you so of course here he is
on CNN the media wants to prop him up
because they know it will hurt Trump say
Trump slash DeSantis take a look
um Trump uh last night in response to
you running uh ran a rather mocking uh
video on social media
um but there it is it's it's you uh I
guess he's he's making fun of your
weight
um that's his uh
that's his response what did you make of
that what was your response to that you
know uh when I saw Jake I just renewed
in my own mind what a child he is he's a
baby
um whenever you want to criticize him I
mean anyway that's the way he responds
and you and I are both lucky enough to
be parents
um and if we had a child who conducted
themselves like that
um we'd send them to their room yeah not
to the White House yeah um and I think
character is Destiny
for this country and we've got to make a
decision about what the character of the
person should be who sits behind the
desk in the Oval Office and if they're
going to do that kind of stuff I mean it
doesn't even it's it's it's so childish
it's so juvenile he is such a spoiled
baby that you know I beyond that what
can you even say about something like
that that's that ridiculous you know I
didn't if we want to break news here
today
um I struggled with my weight for about
20 years like tens of millions of
Americans the devil you said right
exactly
um so he's breaking news there he's
telling people something they don't know
um in the end for me
um it's about how you perform as a
person yeah what kind of heart you have
and I'll put mine up against his any day
in the week
actually I actually agree with
everything that Liz said about uh
Christie earlier in terms of the what's
the purpose of the campaign but you know
I am kind of over the antic stuff with
Trump and like that that whole thing I I
actually don't think it works I guess it
was refreshing that it went to somebody
else instead of DeSantis for one day but
what do you make of of that thing with
Trump at this point
I mean I'm not I'm not a trump supporter
I never was and uh this to me looks more
the same I actually think Trump had a
lot of brilliant policies I mean I lived
in Israel for 20 years until pretty
recently and
he changed life he changed life in the
Middle East that's a fact however I
agree with what Christie says there that
character is destiny that that's what
matters in the white house and I agree
with that with regard to Trump but I
also agree with that with regard to
Christie himself I mean this is a guy
who for political Revenge shut down
Lanes of one of the most important
bridges in New York City to get revenge
on some mayor from Jersey for not voting
for her not endorsing him for for mayor
I'm sorry for for governor
thousands and thousands of people
suffered from that every single day
sitting in traffic because he wanted to
to to have this Petty revenge on this
mayor and again with the beach thing you
know he's sitting on a beach that he
shut down that is not character and
that's why I you know Chris Christie's
way to me makes no difference I don't I
wouldn't make fun of someone because of
that I think that's wrong of course it's
the actual actions in office that
Christy took that still irk me and I was
in New York during that time 2014-15 I
could see the traffic and you think this
was just one guy's whim and one guy
exacting revenge and this is the guy who
is now casting aspersions on somebody
else's character yeah I remember that I
mean he closed down these Lanes the
George Washington Bridge it was a big it
was a big scandal at the time but okay I
think we're all sort of in agreement on
where the campaign itself is going to go
the the other guy that announced
obviously was former vice president uh
Mike Pence he then did it CNN Town Hall
I thought this was the most interesting
snippet from it sir on Donald Trump
quote Inc
ardin many members of the mob who
attacked the capitol on January 6. those
people were of course part of the same
mob who built Gallows and chanted about
wanting to hang you
would you consider partying and
pardoning any of them
you know on the day of January 6 I
issued a tweet
demanding that people leave the Capitol
and end the violence
and I said that those that failed to do
that should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law
and I continue to believe that today
we cannot ever allow what happened on
January 6 to happen again in the heart
of our democracy and I'll stand by the
decisions and the due process of court
in our laws and I I have no interest or
no intention of pardoning those that
that assaulted police officers
vandalized our Capital they need to be
answerable to the law
Liz I think it's worth noting that Trump
didn't pardon any of those people when
he had the chance he also didn't raise
funds for them or anything else he was
president and could have done something
in those last days he did not but
Pence's answer I suspect you're you're
not digging
no I find that answer infuriating first
of all we don't know who erected that
Gallows because we haven't gotten the
full video tape footage of everything
that happened on January 6th so he is
actually casting aspersions on
conservatives when he doesn't know that
that is the case that's the first thing
and by the way we do know we do know
that there were at least 20 feds right
we know that there were at least 20 feds
and probably more on the ground there
oh far more 20 is a small number 20 is
about the number that embedded just with
the proud boys or The Oath Keepers let
alone the entirety of those protests in
and around the capitol he says he stands
by due process of law vice president
Pence what do process of law are you
talking about are you talking about the
two years of pre-trial detention in
solitary confinement that many of these
defendants suffered
um for what for for going through a
barrier that had been broken down for
not committing any violence not
committing any vandals and not harming
anyone not assaulting a police officer
are you talking about the conviction of
a man who didn't bring a weapon into the
capital who didn't tell anybody to bring
a weapon into the capital who didn't
even enter the capital didn't tell
anybody to enter the capital and because
of the content of his private text
messages saying edgy things that our
government didn't like he is now
convicted to 18 years in prison this is
beyond disqualifying for vice president
Pence Beyond disqualifying there is not
a single Republican or conservative
regardless of what you think of what
happened on Jan January 6 regardless of
whether you think the people should have
been there regardless of whether some
people committed vandalism and some
people should be held accountable under
the law for that there's not a single
Republican that should ever cast a vote
for a man that stands by how the
government has weaponized law
enforcement and our Criminal Justice
System against these American citizens
Liz the thing with you is I can never
tell how you really feel you know you're
always you're always you're always high
you're always hiding it always hiding it
let me say this Dave yeah let me say
this let me say this this is a topic
that I get tremendous Flack for talking
about because people say oh it's a
conspiracy theory or you're siding with
people who said horrible things which
some of them did or did things they
shouldn't have done like vandalize and
they shouldn't have done that but let me
tell you the reason that the left is
using January 6th and these prosecutions
as political prosecutions is for that
exact reason for the same reason that
Twitter kicked Alex Jones off first
because so many people don't want to
defend what these people said or did but
that doesn't justify violating people's
constitutional rights to due process of
law and targeting them because they dare
to support Trump and dare to question
the outcome of the 2020 presidential
election I will never stop talking about
this obviously I feel very passionate
about this and Republicans should not
fall for well some establishment figures
like Pence and the left and the media
telling us that everything's just A-Okay
here it's not to Ashley to to Liz's
point I mean who it's sort of like the
Christie question I mean who does he
think is his base I mean I suppose
there's a certain amount of Evangelical
Christians and that that's just great
but they still love Trump for the most
part so it's sort of like where is the
base that you're going for especially
because you're also saying you're going
to go after the people who supported him
most on January 6th so it's like what
are we doing here
I I think you know it's probably
something like Newsome um where you're
hoping or waiting for something to
happen that knocks out the front runner
in Biden's case that could be so many
things
um and in Trump's case I think we
probably know what that is intended to
be which is in some indictment or
something on the legal side is going to
succeed in knocking him out and then it
levels the playing field for people like
Christie and Pence so I think they're
playing this kind of b game like Newsome
is as well
all right I want to do one other thing
for you guys because we have not talked
about the view for the 38 minutes that
we have been live but contractually I
have to do it there was a you know the
view was just so absolutely ridiculous
Barbara Walters is rolling over in her
grave the whole thing is such a
ridiculous farce but for some reason a
certain set of people pay attention to
it and I would like to wake up those
people and it's also on at the exact
time as us right now which I take a
certain pleasure in
um but Sunny Hosten who I think is
genuinely the most unlikable person on
television and as I said Joy Reed is on
television so that's a hell of a
freaking statement for me to make she
got into it with Alyssa Farah now Alyssa
Farah is the quote-unquote conservative
at the table so you've got you know four
lefties basically and then like a pet
conservative and they got into a fight
that I just think is so like emblematic
of everything wrong with television and
media and politics and the whole damn
thing take a look I think he wants power
I think he wants so much power that in
20 17 he closed public beaches to all of
New Jersey except for his family and his
son so he could have his son's birthday
party on the beach I think how does he
get power by entering the race I think
he thinks he's special but what scares
me Alyssa is that you are incapable of
Defending a man that you worked for that
you know why don't you ask me a question
I did ask you a question
and you said that you needed to hear
more from him and I don't need to hear
more from Pence for several reasons
because when I lived will you just
accuse me of something so why don't you
let me actually answer you're not going
to vote for a pumpkin now I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna finish what I'm gonna
say
um the thing about Pence here is that
when I lived in Indiana and I went to
Notre Dame he had a terrible approval
rating because of the way he treated the
AIDS crisis
full a lot of people died because of him
a lot of people died because of how he
handled the covid crisis
he also was a parrot for Trump don't
experience
are you going to give me a chance
spearheading troop uh trumps
agenda of downplaying the virus this is
not what the show is about this is
Barbara Walters everybody
and
[Applause]
okay yeah Ashley like is it like this
like I can feel like a tumor growing in
mind I hate you Dave yeah I apologize to
you guys I apologize to everyone
watching I apologize to my team here why
would I do this to any of us but but
there is something interesting about
that because Sunny Hosten is just laying
out a lot of very very partisan nonsense
that somehow Pence killed people and you
know because of kovid and all that stuff
but in a way the reason I wanted to show
it to you is that uh Alyssa Farah to me
is just getting exactly what she has
paid to get which is to be abused you
sit there and you make I don't know
probably 700 Grand or something like
that a very nice salary to be abused uh
Ashley Authority versus on this one like
does doesn't that whole clip like a
lefty lecturing a conservative a
conservative say I don't have somebody
help me it's just perfect for what
mainstream media is right
yeah it's a it's uh daytime soaps I mean
just with a news Focus
um instead of a love story at the center
of it so uh a hate story but you know I
think in the meantime what we're seeing
is that we have Robert F Kennedy Jr on a
Twitter space with Elon Musk and a few
other people talking about serious
issues in a serious and civil way that's
the difference civil people who are who
come from different parts of the
political Spectrum disagreeing with each
other being civil and that's not what we
get on TV because the incentives on TV
are not for civil or civic-minded
engagements for the very opposites for
for for controversy for Discord for all
that kind of stuff that that gets the
advertisers jazzed up
Liz it's interesting because look Alyssa
is obviously well compensated and again
she's just getting exactly what they pay
her for but someone like you could sit
in that seat right like you you would
you would knock it out of the park which
is why they'd never hire you for that my
friend Lisa Booth who is absolutely
awesome and fearless uh they had at one
point maybe said that she could be there
but she was not vaxed so they wouldn't
even let her in studio to audition uh I
guess I have a couple questions for you
would you even consider the gig and uh
what do you make of just what happened
there or do you have any sympathy for
someone like Alyssa I suppose who's
let's say maybe a little bit on more art
side of things but is what it is
no I have no sympathy for Alyssa she's a
very silly person she is an intellectual
lightweight and she needs to act like a
grown woman if someone is attacking you
then you need to know how to defend
yourself if someone is steamrolling you
for the purposes of humiliating you so
that they they portray to the world that
your political views are somehow
illegitimate then you need to interrupt
and you need to do it in a way that
actually interrupts not not fluster and
flap around like a like an agitated bird
like she does no I don't have a lot of
Sympathy For That being said Sunny
Huston is like a very mean person she's
a very nasty person
um so I I if I were in Alyssa's seat
that would not be happening but like I
said Alyssa it needs to act like a grown
woman and this wouldn't happen to her
Dave uh I have been I I underwent the
same process that Lisa Booth did and you
stopped those negotiations with me for
the same reason that they stopped those
with uh Lisa Booth because I am proudly
unvaccinated I did not receive the
covid-19 jab and at the time their their
rule was nobody in studio who did not
receive the kova 19 jab so it it is what
it is you know I'm not someone that I
mean I'm not I'm not you know sitting
here crying over it it would have been
it would have been a fun gig but it also
would have been a very unfun gig to sit
there and be uh weighed down by the
vapid by the vapid uh snarling that
comes from those women around the table
so no Alyssa Alyssa I I think I feel
actually more aggravated with Alyssa
than I actually do with the Liberals
because this is what I expect from
leftist women I expect them to behave
like that but Alyssa should know better
she should know better
um she should know her policy better she
should know how to debate better she
shouldn't get so emotional so easily
about oh this is personal like who cares
everything's personal of course it is
make your point argue your facts so that
other people understand that policies
are personal and you can your policies
better serve them as people so I think I
find that more annoying because they
hired her specifically so that they
could humiliate conservative opinions
and unfortunately she is um doing that
very effectively right I love that
moment where she turns to the crowd like
hey could you guys help me there's
nothing I can do here because somebody
could some man can you imagine how
different that show would be and
actually I look I don't want to
resurrect direction of that show I think
it's too late for a lot of these
dinosaurs but like imagine you and Lisa
as the conservatives on that show versus
a couple of the you know versus joy and
whoopee and throwing and sunny or
whoever like man that would be so
fundamentally different and better uh
but speaking of better I think you guys
did a fine job today I thank you for
joining us uh have a great weekend to
the two of you we are going to continue
for all our locals members at
reubenreport.locals.com we do the post
game show every day we'll be there in
about 22 seconds uh thanks Liz thanks
Ashley thanks for watching everybody and
see you on the other side
he would later write that it was quite
easy for me to think of a god of love
mainly because I grew up in a family
where love or Central
[Music]
foreign